point o is the center of both circles in
the figure above if the circumference of
the larger circle is 36 so the
circumference of the larger circle there
is 36 and the radius of the small circle
is half the radius of the larger circle
what is the length of the darkened arc
so if you have half the radius you're
going to have half the circumference and
we could we could even solve for what
that radius is so you want to know what
the radius of the larger circle is
well the larger circle we could say
2 pi times its radius is equal to
36 and so its radius if you divide both
sides by 2 pi
its radius is going to be equal to 36
divided by 2 is 18 over pi that's the
larger circle now the smaller circle has
a radius half of the radius of the
larger circle so the smaller circle's
radius is
so radius and i'll write a little sub s
there for the radius of the smaller
circle is going to be half this it's
going to be 9 over pi
and so the circumference of the smaller
circle
the circumference of the smaller circle
is going to be its radius 9 over pi
times 2 pi
and so pi divided by pi or and so you're
going to have 9 times 2 is equal to 18.
and so the circumference here is
and it might have already jumped out at
you because circumference is directly
proportional to because circumference
for any circle is directly proportional
to a radius
if you have half the radius you're going
to have half the circumference and you
wouldn't have had to go through all of
this you could say hey okay if i have a
radius here of 36 and if i have or if i
have a circumference here of 36 and if i
have a circle with half the radius its
circumference is going to be half that
it's going to be 18. but that's not what
they're asking us they're not asking us
just the circumference of the smaller
circle they're asking us what is the arc
length what is the arc length of this
part right over here this 80 degrees
well 80 degrees remember to go all the
way around the circle is 360 degrees so
this is
8360 of the entire of the entire
circle right over here of the entire
circumference so if you want that arc
length it's going to be the
circumference times
eighty three sixtieths times eighty over
three sixty and that's the same thing as
let's see divide both of them by ten
that's the same thing as eight thirty
sixths and let's say you could divide
eight divided by four is 2 and then 36
divided by 4 is 9.
and then you are left with let's see 18
divided by 9 is 2 so you're left with 2
times 2
is equal to
4 and you're done